[ Chuckling ]
Get into these boots, y'all!
Get into these boots!
It's so good to be here.
I'm so happy to be back
in New York.
I moved last year
from Brooklyn to Georgia
to save the democracy.
You're welcome.
[ Applause ]
It was me.
I usually say that
just to see who doesn't clap.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sure they're here.
I moved down there to vote
but also, obviously,
to get a gun,
because when in Rome...
[ Laughter ]
And by "Rome,"
I mean Rome, Georgia.
You register to vote there,
it comes with a Smith & Wesson.
Oh, my goodness. I'm so happy.
It's, like, weird because
the South is a true dichotomy.
You know, I'm hard now.
I'm a gun owner.
But I'm also soft.
I say "good morning" to people.
-[ Laughter ]
-I'm a Jersey girl.
We don't do that above
the Mason-Dixon line, okay?
I brought that back
up to New York City.
People think
New Yorkers are tough.
You want to scare a New Yorker?
Smile, look them in the eyes,
and say, "Good morning."
Yeah, they will think
you about to rob them.
Only thing worse is somebody
asked me for the time once.
I said,
"I will mace you in your face.
'What time is it?'
Where is your cellphone?"
[ Laughter ]
If they laugh, I don't care.
[ Laughs ]
I actually miss things.
I miss flying,
which I never thought
in the pandemic I would miss.
The last place I went
before everything went down
was to Burlington, Vermont.
I don't know
if anybody's ever been there,
but let's just say there were
more Black Lives Matter signs
than Black lives.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-[ Applause ]
-It was a weird place.
I got off that plane. I said,
"Is this north of the wall?
What's happening right now?"
Perfect temperatures for
white walkers and ice cream.
[ Laughter ]
I'm used to being the only
Black person somewhere,
but on this flight to Vermont,
I was the only young person.
I thought it was
a flight to heaven.
[ Laughter ]
They was old, old.
They wasn't regular old.
They sat me next to
a 90-year-old white lady.
Why do I know that?
Because she told me.
I didn't ask her a question.
[ Laughter ]
I sat down.
She was like, "I'm 90."
I said, "I'm Black.
I don't know what's happening.
[ Laughter ]
Why are we stating
our demographics?
Is this the Census?"
She was a chatty 90.
I think she was trying
to get all her words out
before the end.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it was weird
'cause I don't usually talk
to people on airplanes.
I'm not a monster.
She was talking to me.
She was telling me stuff
I didn't ask.
I was like,
"Yo, since we're talking,
I didn't know
you could fly that old."
[ Laughter ]
Why we showing I.D.
at the airport
if anybody can get on the plane?
You not allowed to fly a certain
amount of pregnant, right?
That's on sight.
90? That's the end of
the third trimester of life.
Why is she on the plane with me?
I'm not a doctor, Delta,
but death is crowning!
I see it!
[ Laughter ]
I know I sound ageist,
and that's probably
because I am, I think.
There's age minimums.
We need age maximums. Okay?
We need an age maximum
for flights, computer techs...
presidents.
Um...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right. Y'all agree. Y'all agree.
Get that motorcade on track.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
And it was just so weird.
She just kept telling me stuff
I didn't ask,
letting me know she was
going to visit her big sister.
She turned me into a owl.
I said,
"WHO is your big sister?"
[ Laughter ]
And last but not least,
she just, like, didn't know
how to talk to a young Black
person 'cause at one point --
I'm not making this up --
she just started naming
Black people she could remember.
That got awkward real quick
'cause she 90.
She don't know no new Blacks.
She was hitting me
with throw-Blacks.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah. Crazy.
We were talking about music,
and she was like,
"do you know Ella Fitzgerald?"
First of all, how dare you?
Of course,
I know who Ella Fitzgerald is.
She was like, "Ella Fitzgerald
and Nat King Cole
are my favorite singers."
And I wanted the conversation
to be awkward and end,
so I was like what can I say
to make her not want to talk
to me no more?
I was like, "Since we're
talking about favorites...
you know Harriet Tubman?
And Nat Turner.
They're my favorite slaves.
You don't want to talk anymore,
do you?"
She was like, "No.
Moses is my favorite slave."
I was like,
"You know what? Um...
Did you just out-slave me?
That is rude!"
Moses was a great slave.
Top five.
My name is Joyelle. Thank you,
guys, for listening to me!